I don't know that I'm getting two we're
back now with comedian Sebastian
Maniscalco and his family pediatrician
that would be Dr Scott Cohen they've got
a podcast together it's called daddy
versus doctor where they share parenting
advice and talk candidly about their own
adventures in fathering good morning to
both of you thanks for having us uh so
in the setup package we saw an interview
a conversation with two parents who were
struggling with a baby who will not
sleep this is torture for parents
everyone can relate to it sleep training
is an option but a controversial one so
Dr Cohen yes what do you tell families
about Sleep Train
so anytime after four months the idea of
sleep training is getting a child to
sleep through the night minimum of 10
hours without feeding without picking
them up and usually you can do it in a
healthy child anywhere four months or
after and you're right it's not for
everybody everybody has to make their
own choices but to your point I think
parents are happier when their child's
sleeping through the night relationships
are better and the child's happier and
it actually teaches something really
important you're not starving your child
all those feelings are are self-soothing
right you're not psychologically
damaging them you're actually teaching
them how to self-soothe which is an
important thing for them to learn down
the road and they can learn that
information so my pediatrician told us
that there are three steps to sleep
trimming put the baby in the crib one
close the door come back in the morning
three that's it that sounds simple don't
watch don't watch the baby don't watch
the monitor they're good there's gonna
be crying but that is if you've got the
noise canceling headphones but Tony like
we saw in the piece the mom said I cry
when the baby cries and you say the
words crying it out I know that's a bad
way to try crying it out got a bad name
because it sounds like you're neglecting
your child and you're really not but the
truth is all sleep training is some
variation of letting the child learn to
self-soothe but it's not easy I mean we
we've been through this as parents my
wife has heard me talk about sleep
training so much that her friends used
to call her and she would give the
advice so then when my daughter was four
months she's like we're doing it yeah
easier said than done put her to sleep
10 o'clock she's she's waking up
screaming I'm in bed pretending not to
listen but I'm like dying inside of
course my wife is literally just
shooting me looks shooting me looks and
then all of a sudden she's like done
aborted that night yeah whole next day
we fought I was I was the insensitive
father you're the bad guy she was the
hypocritical mother who gave advice but
couldn't follow it we came to a
consensus we did it later that day my
daughter's been a great sleeper but it's
not easy and not for everybody and
Sebastian you had a Night Nurse right
yeah so growing up we didn't really have
sleep training it was go to bed right
exactly and stop crying
uh we were fortunate enough to have this
woman come in and give us a lot of help
and my kids do have not gotten out of
the bed ever since they don't even know
where our bedroom is so uh it was really
really helpful in that situation and
listen I'm the one that always wants to
go in yeah and you know tend to the baby
my wife is more like just just let him
be I'm a little bit more sensitive now
Sebastian you know you make light of uh
the Daddy's perspective when talking
about family issues kid issues but has
there been a moment or moments where you
just like you've reached your limit but
it's not funny and and you you feel like
it's never really funny in the moment
right but in the reflection of it of
course there's where the morsels of
humor start to kind of pop so yeah uh
sometimes it takes a little time away
from the situation or my sense of humor
to kick in but a lot of times when when
it's happening it's intense like what's
going on everybody says is when they
become a parent they're not going to
lose their temper they're not going to
yell they're going to be a certain kind
of Zen get down on one knee what's going
on tell me what's happening and then
reality sets in how do you get keep
yourself when you feel yourself like
ready to blow keep composure how do you
keep your composure or try to I I don't
um nothing wrong with the little volume
in the house right it's okay right I
mean my wife is always like why are you
getting upset why are you yelling
I cannot suppress a lot of like
sometimes when you get like emotional
about it it's not like I'm walking
around like an animal but at times you
know my voice gets a little loud and and
I think it's good for the kid no please
back me on it
right now yeah it is it absolutely is
you know we we go to you know the kids
bring us to a level we go to the next
it's sort of uh back and forth right
yeah um and it's hard and we've all been
there and I think that's what we found
most about this podcast it's been giving
the feedback we've gotten is that it's
giving parents confidence because you
just want to know as a parent you're
doing doing it right okay and you know
we had that dad last week I mean this
guy should be the poster child of
fathers he was like radiating radiating
glowing and honestly he only called in
just to say am I doing okay am I doing
right by my kids and he was just glowing
about I mean I felt inadequate after he
talked but it was just really nice to be
there to say yeah there's lots of
different right ways of doing it you're
doing a great job when I go back to a
sleep question but not for babies so I
have an 11 year old and you hear all
these things of they need a certain
amount of sleep they need you can't
necessarily get them to sleep and
there's some kids that are like eight
hours or some that are seven is there a
right amount how do you make you can't
make an 11 year old go back to sleep
when they're up at six in the morning
bedrooms right yeah I know what we just
talked about they're not all Sebastian's
kids were afraid to get out of the bed
so there is I mean we look for about 10
hours minimum around four months of age
and as they get older it drops a little
more so nine hours and then eight hours
so in that eight to ten range is great
you're lucky to get eight at least what
we talk about with older kids is getting
into a bedtime routine getting off the
electronics at least an hour before bed
just but if they just get up like if
they are doing all of that are there
just some kids some kids do just get up
early yeah but at least it's their down
time yeah you know and if they're not
waking you up right
just having people talk particularly
fathers uh about parenting it didn't
happen a generation ago not like this
anyway there's not a lot of outlets to
this day uh what are you hoping what are
you hearing actually from other dads who
know this podcast exists well a lot of
like podcasts are like that are male
dominated are talking about sports or
talking about hunting or whatever you
don't really see two guys talking about
so when when your kid doesn't eat what
do you do uh so we're just you know
we're trying to open up that
conversation and it's nice that this is
a platform where fathers could call in
fathers could listen maybe while they're
mowing the lawn and go oh yeah I heard
that on the podcast I'll try it so uh
yeah it's just something different
parents should you know have fun and
we're trying to make it fun to raise
your the kids and and we appreciate my
go-to on a teenager questions here we go
Sebastian Maniscalco and Dr Scott Cohen
thank you so much new episodes of daddy
versus Dr Premiere every Friday
appreciate you guys thank you